welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who keeps getting
demonetized
and this video we're breaking down the
conjuring the devil made me do it
the movie centers around arnie johnson a
man who's literally arrested for
possession
after murdering his landlord there's a
lot of real life things that the film
changes
and in this video we're going to be
discussing the true story that inspired
the film
as well as the film itself full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't had a chance
to check it out then i highly recommend
that you check out now please click the
thumbs up button if you enjoy the video
and make sure you subscribe if you watch
youtube all day
because you hate exercising crap buttons
all through the video
and with that out of the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into the
conjuring
mephisto made me do it
okay so up top i'm going to be
discussing the real life events that
inspired the film
but if you want to jump ahead to our
breakdown of the movie itself then time
codes will be linked below
our story begins in the 1980s with the
possession of an 11 year old boy
named david glatzel ooh spooky music
now after he and his family purchased a
rental property
david started seeing a ghostly figure
that he described as a man with big
black eyes
a thin face with animal features and
jagged teeth
his parents would become angry with him
and say that he made the specter up in
order to avoid doing housework
but david would often reply with highly
sinister threats about what would happen
if they ever tried to leave the house
even though they had simply purchased it
to do it up and rent it out
they decided that now would be as good a
time as any to move in
and this is where things really started
to escalate
david kept telling his parents that the
old man was appearing more and more
and his figure was starting to warp into
a demonic wolf
that cursed at him in latin and said it
would eat his soul
david himself started to change too and
after experiencing multiple seizures and
strange injuries
the family reached out to the church
after they refused they were left asking
who you're gonna call
which is when the glad souls contacted
eden lorraine warren
who liked the movie lived locally the
warrens started observing david
and according to them he levitated at
several points
whereas in the film we just center on
one malevolent entity that focused on
the boy
in real life the paranormal
investigators said that multiple demons
attached themselves to him
this ranged from a number of creatures
totaling up to 43
that all apparently had their eyes on
the boy after the warrens contacted the
church
the family were taken more seriously and
they sent out a priest to carry out an
exorcism
which we see in the opening of the film
now this moment itself has a nod to the
classic horror the exorcist
when the priest arrives and throughout
the film there are some nods to the
shining like when ed chases after
lorraine in a demonic filled rage
but i digress and in total there were
three exorcisms performed
during one david's sister debbie had her
boyfriend arnie attend in order to
comfort her
and it's said that he offered himself up
to the demon as a way to save the young
boy
according to eyewitnesses he was
attacked during this
and when driving home the demon
reportedly tried to steer his car into a
tree
now in the film we watches arnie snoops
about the house
and here he comes face to face with the
demon once more
this actually pulls highly from real
life events as
ani stated he returned to the house by
himself and it's at this point that it
actually took over him after he and the
demon came face to face
see it's not just lorraine's hair that's
accurate in the movie now debbie was
hired by a dog groomer named alan bono
and with arnie they moved into his
property in the film his name is changed
to bruno
probably because the guy still has a
family and it's a bit offensive to paint
his killer out as a nice and friendly
chap that always leaves a like
and the only time that he did something
wrong was because he was possessed by a
demon
so though a minor change i can see why
they did it
and after arnie started exhibiting
strange behavior that was similar to
david's
debbie feared that the demon had taken
over him now on february 16th
1981 arnie came home from work sick
and bono who had been drinking heavily
apparently grabbed debbie's cousin mary
and wouldn't let go johnson tried to
pull him away
and it's at this point that he started
snarling like an animal
and he produced a pocketknife johnson
attacked him with it several times
and it led to the first murder in the
history of brookfield connecticut
now this is where the film and the real
life story start to differ
in the movie we discover that david was
actually the target of an occultist
who placed a witch's totem in the
basement of the property
it's revealed in the movie that a priest
known as castner was sent in to study a
group of satanists
and he got too close to them referred to
as the disciples of the ram
kasna ended up getting far too close to
the abyss and because he took his work
home
it ended up in some ways possessing
someone close to him
castner's daughter too became obsessed
with the occult
and she made a deal with a demon that
involved her carrying out several
ritualistic sacrifices
now as always shout outs to john noble
for playing another deadbeat dad
and you may remember the disciples of
the ram from the annabelle films
in the franchise annabelle actually
ended up joining them
so the inclusion is a nice call back to
those movies
now where the third conjuring film
differs from the rest is that this movie
centers around a curse
rather than your typical possession
after making her pact
the occultist had to offer up several
souls in order to meet the demon's
demands
and these involved a murder and a
sacrifice after arnie was put in prison
and left awaiting trial
she struck from a mystical altar that
allowed her to haunt the character with
visions
which almost forced him to end his own
life however the warrens caught wind of
it
and they started to investigate the
satanic totems
which led them to the unsolved
disappearance of jessica long
after receiving visions lorraine found
that after jessica was possessed
she killed her friend and leaped into a
gorge the connection that her corpse had
with the occultist
allowed lorraine to see an altar that
she performed these rituals from
and in the movie we learned that if one
is to destroy this podium
then the curse will end now trouble
arises when lorraine realizes that the
occultist can two see through this
connection
and after she learns of the warrens she
sends a totem to their home
it's at this point that the film really
starts to move away from the real life
case
which i think is a bit of a shame as i
was really interested in the court case
and how someone would try and explain a
murder by saying that a demon had
possessed them
next time my wife asks me why i haven't
done the dishes i'm just saying that a
demon wouldn't let me anyway
we learned that arnie is living on
borrowed time and that the occultist
plans to take his soul at night
at the prison a priest arrives to watch
over him and debbie helps to stop him
from slitting his throat
as the possession completely takes him
over lorraine returns to castner in
order to ask questions about the
mysterious antagonist
and it's at this point that he reveals
that she's his daughter
using the clues of a train line and
running water which lorraine saw through
the connection
ed figures out that she's in danger and
he heads out to help her as she's forced
to flee into the basement of the home
upon arriving there ed becomes somewhat
possessed by the occultist
and he ends up chasing his wife through
the mines with a hammer
however using their lover memories
lorraine is able to connect with her
husband once more
and he smashes the altar leaving the
occultist owing a soul
the demon returns and takes her and the
movie ends with ed erecting a band stand
similar the one that they stood under
during their first date
cementing their love her erecting her
now we we also see ed place the cup from
the altar in the room for the occult
items
which contains the painting of the nun
as well as annabelle still locked away
in her case
until warner bros of course need to to
get her out to milk this franchise some
more now the film
does sort of tease towards what happened
in arnie's trial
and as this is an ending explained i
thought i'd dive further into this to
talk about his life
shortly after he carried out the crime
lorraine actually contacted the police
to say that he was indeed possessed
and due to his connection with david the
story quickly grew media attention
labelled the demon murder trial
this defensive army being possessed was
thrown out
as there would never be any possible
evidence that could be presented to
uphold this idea
thus the defense actually chose a
different strategy
and instead of going with the hashtag
devil made me do it
johnson's lawyers stated that he acted
in self-defense
this strategy worked and johnson was
convicted of first-degree manslaughter
rather than something that could have
gotten him the death penalty
he was sentenced to 10 to 20 years in
prison but as the film states he only
served five
however the controversy didn't stop
there and after the warrens published a
book on the incident titled the devil in
connecticut
david glatzel and his brother carl
became very angry
they actually sued the publishers of the
book for libel and stated that the
warrens made up the possession story
in order to exploit david's mental
health issues
call in the book was presented as the
bad guy because he was a skeptic and he
said that he only agreed to the story
being told
because the warrens promised them that
they'd make the family millionaires
in total they paid them only two
thousand dollars and carl said that the
negative publicity which surrounded the
story
made him lose friends and employment
opportunities
he actually created his own book arguing
that the supernatural elements were
make-believe
which lorraine disputed she said that
because the church got involved
that it did cement the possession was
real and that the family did want the
story told
which is why they ended up publishing it
now as of writing this arnie and his
wife debbie
do agree with the possession story but
you would say that if you'd murdered
someone and then said it was
a demon did it but never mind they
they've come out and stated
that anything to the contrary by the
glatzels is because they simply wish to
sue in order to make further profit from
it
see kids the real demons are the people
anyway it's a very interesting tale
and it does make for quite a fun movie
now my big issue with the conjuring
franchise in general
is that it relies too heavily on jump
scares
at this point they're just so
telegraphed and beyond jumping out and
going
oh no they're not really that scary
it's not clever it's not intimidating
it's not tense
it's behind you did i get you probably
not but that kind of shows how dumb it
is
now there are of course ways to create
tension and horror without relying on
cheap tactics and i feel like the
conjuring would do well if it tried to
set atmosphere
rather than simply having things pop on
screen to scare you
now what's weird is that these are the
types of tropes that expect from a low
level horror
but the conjuring movies normally have a
pretty solid cast
and i have to say that vera amiga and
parrik wilson
again do a fantastic job they continue
to get better and better each movie
and this is definitely my favorite
conjuring film i would love it if we
spent more time with the court case
rather than going off into the
fantastical as i think that's far more
interesting than anything centered
around demons attempting to possess
people
however i know that's not what these
movies are for and i
can't really blame it for not meeting my
expectations when it was never gonna go
that route
like i said i enjoyed it and if you love
these types of movies
then you definitely will too if you
don't then you're probably still gonna
have a fun ride
but i don't think it's gonna change the
genre or be remembered
20 minutes from now however the
conjuring the devil made me do it was
good
and it gets a 10 out of 10. sorry the
devil made me do that
it's a 7. anyway i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film so make sure you
comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla versus kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of army of
the dead which will be linked on screen
right now
we've gone over all the unanswered
questions to discuss what's really going
on in the film
and it's definitely worth checking out
if anything in that movie confused you
without the way thank you for singing
through the video i'll be mephisto
i'll see you next time take care peace